foreign
's with us Roxanne's in Anaheim
California hi Roxanne welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi there thank you for taking my call my
pleasure I'm a bit nervous
pardon me well listen Roxanne I almost
sang your name does that happen all the
time
yeah take a shot every time you say my
name huh I didn't I almost did I did
people used to call me deloney bologna
all the time growing up and so I didn't
want to contribute to the madness of
your life so there you go
don't be nervous
um thank you okay I've got a few things
going on I am I've got about fifty
thousand dollars in credit card debt
uh
I'm about seventeen thousand dollars
with a business loan I try to start a
small business and I have no customers
right now so I have no money coming in
so now I'm looking for work
um I'm starting to get I'm six months
behind on my business loan I'm late on
my credit card and I don't know where to
go
um do I take my 401k out to pay these
this
this debt
because of the interest rates are just
killing me do I take out a personal loan
do I write my credit card companies uh
I'm sure whatever it's going to take me
a few months to catch up just to my own
personal debt uh so he hi what do I do
scary isn't it
um yeah are you single
I am married
okay what does he make
[Music]
how long have you guys been married
for a little over 20 years okay
well you're about 19 years late on
combining your finances yeah yeah
yes we are yeah because you know my wife
is not going to be late on things when I
make 200 000 a year I'm married to her
for better for worse
for richer for Porsche you're not his
roommate you're his wife
right so what is he saying about all
what's he saying about your debt being
behind and you're not having a job
one
kind of just ignoring it pretending like
it's not happening because I I always
have a way to figure it out Roxanne does
he know how bad it is
um not really no it's time for you to
come clean
and it's gonna be a moment of sadness
and shame and there's probably going to
be some other Ripple effects because
there's probably been some other stuff
over the 20 years that you all haven't
told each other but you got to come
clean
and together other together we have
about a hundred thousand dollars in IRS
debt so I we have been keeping our
financials separate
um to get together you have a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars in debt and
he makes two hundred thousand and you're
getting ready to get a job and start
making money so you're gonna have 300
000 or whatever coming into this house
and you're going to clean up that
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
debt in about a year and a half if you
will finally combine your finances and
quit acting like roommates
the UK and just say together we can do
anything separately we suck
yeah
but that involves you not having so much
pride I'll clean up my own mess or him
not being a jerk saying you clean up
your own mess uh but you guys are
missing out on some of the best parts of
marriage because you're stiff arming
each other
yeah yeah I definitely pride is takes
place in there because I've worked my
whole life and oh well you're not it's
not that you're not of value it's not
that you're not of value it's not that
you need a keeper that's not the point
the point is it's for better for worse
and sickness and health if you got
cancer he's supposed to take care of you
and you didn't do anything wrong there
okay I mean you may have made some
mistakes with money uh but welcome to
being a human walking around in America
if you're if you made mistakes with
money you're over 12. so here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna be in Anaheim
doing a a Building Wealth event on May
the 5th and
um I think it's the fifth or something
may something like that and um no it's
right it's right before that uh for a
second or so yeah okay or early May and
uh we're gonna have Austin pick up and
he's going to give him a second he's
going to pick up and give you two VIP
tickets for you and your husband that
means that I'm gonna get to meet you
we'll take a picture with you but you're
going to be there for the Building
Wealth live event I'm also going to give
you Financial Peace University but you
have to do it together Roxanne
Now's the Time Now's the Time okay all
this stuff if I can stand on my own or
uh or he doesn't need to help or he
thinks he's too cool to help or whatever
the is in this chemistry of this
conversation has got to be wiped clean
and your two newlyweds smiling and
looking at the rest of your life
together
and going we're going to combine
everything and we're gonna take on the
world and the IRS and we're going to win
on both fronts so you can do this